the Swiss court has just sentenced a
writer to 2 months in jail for calling
an LGBT activist a fat lesbian the
writer was found guilty of defamation on
Monday and the verdict was immediately
praised by the lesbian activist Group
Los as quote an important moment for
justice and rights of lgbtqi people in
Switzerland which means he was found
guilty of defamation for calling her a
lesbian and the verdict was praised as a
victory for lesbian rights I don't think
that men should ever call women fat and
I don't think men even should ever call
women lesbians but if the victory is a
if the verdict rather is a victory for
lesbian rights then that implies that
the victim was a lesbian which means
that he did not defame her he was just
sort of impolite which is not good but
does an impolite remark really Merit 60
days in jail